[Music]
this is a recent this is a recent
realization I made in my life there is
no way to pick up pills that you've
spilled on the ground without looking
like a total human red flag you know
there's this no way to be like oh oh
this is what I meant to do and
everything is going great you know it's
usually more along the lines of oh I'm
so sorry
I need these Oh Mama's medicine you know
immediately turns into a dark one-woman
show that no one agreed to attend I am
on a healthy diet of pills they are
prescribed for the most part one of the
things I take them for is depression
it's always a great to start off a set
talking about depression cuz people are
like I guess you can have it all you
know yeah uh yeah I got depression for
pretty much my whole life and I've
learned to manage it for the most part
but a lot of times I'll still feel sad
for no reason but then I'll remember the
reasons
this actually makes a lot of sense adds
up like one of the things I've been
struggling with lately is working from
home I don't know if anyone here works
from home definitely don't clap you've
had a long hard day you guys save those
hands for tomorrow I I find it very hard
to be productive when you work from home
like I feel like the closest thing I
have to a boss is Netflix when it's like
are you still watching
and like of course I'm still watching
I am never not watching stop
micromanaging me I'm your best employee
I take all your suggestions in other
news I am recently still single
thank you yeah yeah I I broke up with my
last boyfriend two years ago and you
know it looks like we're keeping it
break up that's our thing you know like
being apart that's like our thing I've
been trying to date I have a couple of
issues with dating one of them is like
on dates it's like you have to show up
and be fun it's like what are you a king
are you you should just be glad that I'm
real there's a lot of demands right out
of the gate and you know I've been
trying I've been trying online dating
like I'm finally on the internet got my
AOL CDM on there but I feel like I've
tried a range of sites you know I spent
some time on match put in my dues on
okcupid's
like a month on Yelp like I feel like
I've gone the distance
just not clicking but yeah I live in New
York right now it's why I smell
different you know hint of garbage but
it's very hard it's very hard to keep
your confidence up in New York like no
one tells you this when you move there
but there are just models walking around
all the time just like unregulated yeah
there's a fair of the models wandering
the streets that nobody warns you about
some of them are like free-range
I guess but models are very tricky
species of human like I feel like
they're always stepping out of buildings
when you least expect it just like
ruining your day and you know I I feel
sometimes people tighten up on that
they're like don't criticize our most
precious resource and I get that I feel
like they should be allowed to exist but
just keep them away from me like models
are like self-esteem pickpockets they
they're fine from a distance you can
appreciate them from afar like a sunset
but if you ever directly walk by one
within seconds it's just like I have
nothing
even my personalities are wrong shape
you know it's immediately like rock
bottom you gotta grab an O Magazine
rebuild from scratch back to basics
back to basics I'll leave you guys with
this thought to ponder do you guys think
if two DJ's got in a fight in a
nightclub
they just keep yelling oh the tables
have turned at each other
[Applause]
you